[Applause]
the time has come Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker is here and the critics are
officially weighing in with mixed
reviews so let's take a look at what
they're saying about the final film in
the skywalker saga right now on the
culture as of the time of the taping the
rise of skywalker is coming in at 57% on
the tomato meter with a hundred and
fifty-one reviews the critics consensus
is that it suffers from a frustrating
lack of imagination but concludes this
beloved saga with fan focus devotion but
it's Star Wars and the reviews will keep
coming so stay tuned Iran tomatoes for
the latest update now fans and critics
had a lot of questions going into the
rise of Skywalker especially after 2017
the last Jedi which is certified fresh
at 91% but faced major backlash on
social media over some of the decisions
that were made so a common sentiment
among critics like screen rants Molly
Freedman is that the rise of Skywalker
gets bogged down in exposition and
course-correcting the last Jedi but does
have some fun moments and fanservice
with Richard Roeper from the Chicago
sun-times saying there are a few moments
when it feels as if this movie is trying
to satisfy every Star Wars fanatic in
the world but how would be beyond the
scope of even the most impressive Jedi
Mind Tricks of course we'll be with you
always
and many feel that one way Disney tried
to correct the perceived problems with
the last Jedi directed by Rian Johnson
was to bring back JJ Abrams who also
directed the force awakens and critics
like Andy wires Eric Conn took notice of
the attempts to play it safe by saying
Abrams excels at transforming
established popular culture into a
greatest hits showcase and his return to
the director's chair signaled that
Disney wanted more of the same and time
Stephenie zakharik added in its anxiety
not to offend it comes off more like fan
fiction than the creation of actual
professional filmmakers a bot would be
able to pull off a more surprising movie
never underestimate a droid and the
carrick also pointed out another common
complaint critics we're having with this
movie there's just a lot going on she
said stuff happens in the rise of
Skywalker and just when you think stuff
is gonna stop happening it keeps
happening but some of that stuff is
being considered bright spots for the
film including all the really great
action in the battles of brain I will
read the re-emergence of Lando
Calrissian and the introduction of some
new characters Vanity Fair's Johanna
Robinson tweeted I'll say this I frickin
love Zuri bliss and Babu Frank love with
Thrillist Steve Gonzales adding all hail
Babu Frick and Zoe blaze who are my
favorite things from the second they
show up but to keep this movie in the
two-and-a-half hour range and not three
hours like Avengers endgame not much
time was spent with the new characters
because well they had to wrap up a
full-on saga
and despite the flaws critics have found
with the film many feel it does hit the
landing like the San Francisco
Chronicle's Mick LaSalle who wrote the
rise of Skywalker does the most
important thing the one thing it
absolutely had to do it ends well and
the Chicago Tribune is Michael Phillips
said it does a job it wraps up the trio
of trilogies begun in 1977 any confident
soothingly predictable way others like
USA TODAY's Brian Truitt weren't as
satisfied saying after paying homage to
everything that came before this Star
Wars ending is a to safe landing of a
massive pop culture starship and a
spectacular finale then this is a chance
to forge something special all right
guys for all of you that are sad about
the Skywalker saga coming to a close
just know that the future of Star Wars
is bright and Kathleen Kennedy is
actually expected to announce more Star
Wars news in the new year
alright peeps it is now time for you to
weigh in on a conversation we'll
probably be having until the end of time
what are your thoughts are you excited
to see the rise of Skywalker and what
are you hoping to get from this film let
us know all your feelings in the comment
section and for more Star Wars news head
on over to Rotten Tomatoes home and be
sure to click that subscribe button and
notification bell so you don't miss any
future catch-up episodes as always I'm
nice Prez thank you for watching to
catch up and may the force be with you
[Music]
you